i want to play a game across the saw
franchise there have been a hundred
total deaths but keep in mind they
weren't all committed by me my followers
are numerous and their talents have
served me well a doctor for medical
procedures a detective to hide our work
former survivors of my games who've gone
on to rehabilitate others and yet across
nine movies one of my partners has
stayed silent one has been hidden in
plain sight never revealed prying eyes
my secret accomplice today i lay out the
clues that you've missed that spell out
who he is and you'll never watch this
franchise the same way again like or
subscribe make your choice
[Applause]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show where killer content sometimes
means content about killers today we're
diving back into the saw franchise to
take a closer look at jigsaw's murder
operation i've never murdered anyone
fine then uh let's go with super deadly
rehabilitation racket whatever you call
it though working for jigsaw has got to
be like the worst gig ever you get long
night shifts you get poor job security
you're constantly working in dirty
bathrooms ripping sewers just generally
unhygienic conditions i mean what is
this amazon booyah got him with the
topical humor and just like with amazon
if the employees started to unionize for
better working conditions well we all
know what would happen over time the
movies reveal that at least five other
people or apprentices have been part of
jigsaw's organization helping him find
victims and set up games i suppose
teamwork truly does make the dream work
but for as large as jigsaw's
organization became the films never
truly explain who's helping jigsaw study
his targets and learn their patterns
pre-abduction there seems like there's a
missing piece to this puzzle a missing
apprentice someone who's yet to be
revealed as part of team jigsaw i
believe that person to be none other
than adam stanheit the victim from the
first film and pretty much the first
person we meet in the entire series not
only do i think that he survived the
events of the first film i think we can
then lay a groundwork of evidence
proving he joined up with jigsaw after
the events of the movie and maybe just
maybe set up the dominoes that would
ultimately kill jigsaw once and for all
for those of you who need a refresher as
to who exactly adam is in the first saw
film we're immediately met with one of
the most iconic images in all of horror
history two men adam and dr gordon both
shackled to a disgusting bathroom floor
as part of jigsaw's game you see jigsaw
aka john kramer seeks to test people who
don't appreciate their lives and
jigsaw's beef without him is that he
just sat on the sidelines a freelance
photographer who spied on adulterous
couples someone who has paid to watch
shady people do shady things instead of
actually taking action adam had actually
been hired to follow around his fellow
player in the game dr gordon who was the
prime suspect for the jigsaw murders at
the time by the end of the movie dr
gordon saws off his own foot shoots at
him and crawls out of the bathroom in
order to survive he's later nursed back
to health by jigsaw and goes on to
become one of his faithful followers as
for adam well he's left to realize that
the true jigsaw was in the room with him
the entire time john cramer rises out of
a pool of blood and gives us this iconic
finale
the first movie ends with adam's fate
unclear we're left to assume that adam
just bleeds to death in the bathroom
still shackled to the floor that is
until saw three when we see a flashback
as to what really happened after the
first movie ended we see amanda another
of jigsaw's proteges trying to suffocate
adam to death to put him out of his
misery and this is where adam's story is
believed to have ended as we later see
his nasty decayed corpse still chained
to the floor and both saw two and saw
the final chapter so if he's dead why
would i possibly think that he could be
jigsaw's secret accomplice well let's
start by taking a closer look at adam's
supposed death scene in saw 3 amanda is
shown to be suffocating adam for 36
seconds before she breaks down in tears
and the scene abruptly ends and we know
that this is meant to be a roughly
accurate estimation of time because the
scene doesn't have many cuts from the
moment that the bag goes over his head
here's the thing about that though 30
seconds without oxygen probably isn't
enough to kill him according to past
studies it takes approximately 30
seconds to three minutes to render
someone unconscious severe neurological
damage starts at around the three minute
mark and brain death occurs around the
five minute mark if oxygen is restored
within three minutes then a person can
feasibly recover now admittedly when
dealing with oxygen deprivation mere
seconds could make the difference
between life death and irreparable
damage so suffocation isn't something to
take lightly and factors like adam's
head trauma his panicked response his
weakened state all of that could have
impacted his overall survival but
looking purely at the timing here it's
likely that he was just knocked out
during the scene heck adam went nearly
that long without oxygen at the start of
the film when he was in the tub in fact
to get amanda to stop her attack adam
could have easily been playing dead
which is a tactic that he employed
previously in the game
all right he wasn't great at it but
maybe he picked up a tip or two after
witnessing a pro it's also worth noting
that we never get confirmation of his
death here the scene cuts away pretty
much immediately after adam stops
struggling and when it comes to saw if a
death isn't definitively shown on the
screen then the character always comes
back we've seen this before with other
characters like dr gordon agent perez
detective matthews speaking of detective
matthews by the way he serves as an
interesting case here because like adam
he too was supposed to be killed by
amanda again in saw three we see that
she supposedly beat him to death but
left before making sure the deed was
done sure enough he survived and not
only did he survive jigsaw sent one of
his accomplices to retrieve him and
secretly nurse him back to hell in short
lots of people get secretly nursed back
to health in these movies and amanda has
herself a track record of not fully
killing people off in fact it's more
than possible that jigsaw did something
similar here in saw three when amanda
claims that she's a murderer jigsaw
responds that he's been cleaning up her
mistakes emphasis on the plural he took
my life from me
i just returned a favor no amanda that's
what you thought
but i know differently
you left him for dead didn't you but i
cleaned up your mistakes
and i forgave you for them he didn't
want his protege committing murders that
broke his rules that's why jigsaw had an
accomplice intervened to save detective
matthews but to the best of our
knowledge matthews was really her only
quote unquote mistake so why would
jigsaw say that this is plural well the
jigsaw 3 director's cut shows that when
amanda snuck off to kill adam jigsaw
woke up and eyed her with suspicion it's
an interesting detail to include
especially considering that this is the
director's cut so it's footage that he
felt was important enough to get added
back into the story that he wanted to
tell if jigsaw truly pieced together
that she was gonna go kill adam he could
have called upon one of his other
accomplices to swing by the bathroom and
clean up yet another of her mistakes but
here's the clincher the most compelling
piece of evidence that adam's death was
faked look at the corpse left in the
bathroom that we see in both saw two and
final chapter notice that it has the
shackle on the right foot but throughout
the bathroom game adam is shown to have
the shackle on his left foot put his
left leg in the shackle this would seem
like a massive production detail to get
wrong not just once but twice when
trying to faithfully recreate the first
film set down to the smallest detail
there is no way a mix-up like this could
have happened by accident the only
reason for the shackle to wind up on the
wrong foot here is if someone unshackled
adam and then switched him out with a
corpse in order to fake his death but
the evidence for adam's involvement here
doesn't just stop at him being alive and
potentially nursed back to health
remember that adam's job prior to the
bathroom game was taking surveillance
photos sounds like it'd be a useful
skill for a killer who profiles victims
and then abducts them from their daily
routine does it not so is it any
coincidence then that after adam's test
black and white photographs of victims
become a prominent part of jigsaw's
operation nearly all of the victims in
saw four five six and the final chapter
have photographs taken of them many of
them seemingly taken unknowingly while
the victims were being watched from afar
one after another after another enough
to fill an entire photo album but where
did these candid photos come from
someone must have been taking
surveillance of the victims and who do
we see taking photos just like these
adam granted photographs did
occasionally show up in jigsaw's
operation prior to the bathroom game
hello mark
if you're so sick
then why do i have so many photos of
however perhaps adam's involvement goes
back even further than we've been led to
believe with jigsaw anonymously
enlisting adam's surveillance talents
before he was ever tested after all adam
is established to not ask a lot of
questions when dealing with mysterious
clients he calls himself bob and he
gives me the money up front 200 bucks a
night
i know i was gonna end up here i would
have asked for a hell of a lot more in
fact it's probable that jigsaw may have
even hired adam to help him track down
his first victim ever cecil the man that
assaulted jigsaw's wife and cost the
couple their unborn child software goes
to great lengths to depict nearly every
step of jigsaw preparing for his first
killing it's an important one in his
backstory after all and yet for all the
meticulous detail it shows in the
planning process the film never shows us
how jigsaw actually tracked down cecil's
whereabouts in the first place all of a
sudden jigsaw's just shown to be in
possession of a bunch of photographs
with a file with an address on it that
someone presumably provided him it's
very possible that jigsaw enlisted adam
to find cecil snap some shots and tail
him back to his home address no
questions asked and from that point
forward jigsaw became a repeat customer
eventually throwing adam into a game
because you know he just has a habit of
doing that to his followers but adam
being alive doesn't just explain where a
bunch of photographs came from it also
fills in the gaps for one of the most
pivotal plot elements in the entire
series jigsaw's death you see jigsaw's
demise is basically the result of an
impossibly complex series of dominoes a
victim named jeff slits jigsaw's throat
because apprentice amanda shot jeff's
wife and amanda shot jeff's wife because
someone else on team jigsaw mark hoffman
blackmailed her into doing it
threatening to tell jigsaw about
amanda's connection to cecile
but wait a minute back up a second how
the heck could hoffman have possibly
known this if this scene between amanda
and cecil had been caught on camera
jigsaw would know too he's seen the
footage and if this information surfaced
as part of a police investigation amanda
would have been charged as an accomplice
so this means that someone who was there
that night must have informed hoffman
about amanda's presence but who could
have done it well funny enough this
pivotal flashback scene from saw four
depicting that fateful evening is packed
with characters from throughout the
series paul from the razer wire trap the
guy from amanda's first game it's a
literal who's who of future jigsaw
victims apparently this was just a night
of wild coincidences most critically
though addison from saw two is shown to
be present even going so far as to
proposition jigsaw yeah honey
i want some company this is important
because adam's photography business
specializes in documenting infidelity i
get paid to take pictures of rich guys
like you who go to cd out of the way
motel therefore adam might have had a
reason for hanging around this corner of
town to be fair the film never outright
shows adam but he could have just been
lurking off screen now that would
obviously sound like me making excuses
except for the fact that the movies pull
this trick repeatedly in fact with this
very same scene amanda evidently was out
of sight the first time this flashback
was shown to the audience only for later
films to reveal that she too was hidden
in the corner the entire time if adam
supplied the ammunition for hoffman to
blackmail amanda that would make adam
the one truly responsible for jigsaw's
death in a way it kind of bookends the
entire series in saw the final chapter
jigsaw told dr gordon that he would keep
no more secrets from him i will keep no
more secrets from you it's never
explained what he meant by this they
just kind of leave that promise hanging
perhaps the biggest secret of all stems
from jigsaw letting gordon live under
the belief that adam was dead when in
fact he was alive and secretly aiding in
the jigsaw operation the entire time
jigsaw initially targeted adam due to
him being a mere voyer that sat in the
shadows watching everyone else commit
their misdeeds but jigsaw's operation
allowed adam to actively intervene in
the lives of those he watched in the end
perhaps jigsaw's lessons ultimately
backfired as the one who had once been
content to sit on the sidelines suddenly
started to play puppet master himself
pulling the strings to pit jigsaw as
followers against each other i guess
adam did learn from the best he finds
ways for his victims to kill themselves
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts
[Music]
you